I think many people have put off math
because they feel like they don't
understand it and that they've been
given the impression that that means
they're not good at it but actually none
of us understands it and that's the
whole point we accept that we will never
fully understand it but we still want to
understand more that drives us to want
to understand more we don't just go oh I
don't understand it it's over we go okay
well I don't understand it yet I'm going
to understand more all the time as for
the unreasonable Effectiveness I sort of
think it's reasonable because it's the
use of reason that's at the core of
everything and as for whether we deserve
it well that's a complicated question
what do humans deserve in one sense we
behave badly we destroy the environment
we're horrible to people we don't
deserve much on the other hand we all
deserve wonderful things because we're
all just trying and so maybe we do
deserve it I don't know that deserving
is something that is easy to work out